this is the fourth lecture of the
Schulman lecture series for the semester
I am a curator of the lecture series
along with my colleague sarah diemer's
sarah is an associate professor in the
physics department I direct the dance
studies curriculum here at Yale my name
is Emily Coates the series title is
physics and dance and it comes out of
our course in which we address
introductory concepts in physics
introductory concepts in dance and
encourage our students to find
connections between them for some this
may seem like an unusual philosophy but
we have codified our vision for
transdisciplinary or interdisciplinary
dialogue and it can be summed up as deep
interdisciplinary dives coupled with
individually driven inquiry so we don't
dictate all connections for our students
we let them forge connections with
knowledge that we're imparting to them I
share all this background because this
is our thinking and curating this
lecture series we've had two esteemed
dance artists speak and we've had two
prominent particle physicists speak
about research in their fields today Liz
Lerman is our linchpin she is someone
who in her choreographic work has strode
boldly across disciplines in the arts in
the humanities and sciences and so
really today she is going to be able to
help us put all of the pieces together
of the lecture series and for the
students in our course some of the
questions that were asking in the class
about interdisciplinary work liz is
known for a number of things in the
choreographic world she's known for her
community work awesome and inspiring
engagement with different kinds of
community
through dance she's known for
multi-generational dance warding defying
the convention in the dance world that
all dance must be performed on youthful
bodies anyone can dance and her cast
tend to be a beautiful spectrum of Ages
religions class ethnicity race Under the
Sun everyone is dancing together
everyone is allowed to dance and
encouraged to dance and she's also known
for what I think of as dance with big
ideas and this I think is what she's
going to be talking to us about today
she has collaborated with physicists she
has gone to CERN researched at CERN made
a performance piece that toured
nationally internationally based on that
work she has also collaborated with
biologists and created a performance
piece in dialogue with knowledge from
biology this is exactly what we're
trying to get and what we're trying to
encourage our students to do we think of
it as deep interdisciplinary dive
coupled with individually driven inquiry
and liz is going to share with us her
exact individual way of going about
forging this connections Liz I should
mention also won a MacArthur award for
her strategies and dance so these are
these are not small feats that she has
charted in the dance world she has
recognized as an innovator and a
revolutionary and delighted to welcome
you here today
it's very nice to have such a personal
introduction Thank You Emily and thanks
for rescheduling for those of you who
might have thought of coming the last
time here okay family matters
and I was called away and I'm just so
glad that it worked out so I could be
back strong feelings for the city having
gotten to do some work with the festival
in the summer and continued to work here
at Yale when I was very very small I had
nightmares my nightmares were kind of
abstract they were dots and the dots
were gonna get me this I was like three
or four and I would wake up screaming
because the room would be full of these
dots they were coming after me and my
mother would come in and we would have a
very nice gentle calming moment and I
laugh about that now because I actually
see the world in dots now it may be the
influence of the biologists and all the
tiny tiny tiny work we did on DNA and
smaller or maybe the physicists and all
the tiny tiny tiny tiny but actually I
think I see the dots and I want to sort
of address something that Emily raised I
sometimes thought of as a person who
made it possible for old people to be
dancing this is kind of foolish old
people have been dancing forever I mean
for thousands and thousands and they may
have been the first answers for all we
know it's just that we forgot about it
in a very small corner of the dance
world in a small corner of history in a
small corner the United States and the
West and we thought actually only young
bodies could dance so I put together
some dots I connected dancing and old
people
and once I made that connection I
started to make a shape and it made it
possible for people to see it's making
these connections of these dots these
constellations and gives us a chance to
see something that's been there all the
time we just didn't see it the reason I
raised this with you is that it makes me
think of the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle and I don't know if they're
physicists in the room but I know that
all artists who entered the world the
physics eventually end up at the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle and the
physicists always roll their eyes
because to them it's not metaphor but
for us it's like but this is my version
of it it's not the it's the way I
paraphrase it but at one part of it and
there are many parts to that principle
it's this if you measure the shape you
will miss the velocity or the momentum
but if you go for the momentum you'll
miss the shape that's what I mean the
momentum the dots are all around us we
make this connection we build this thing
and we say see this is what it is
that's what we did with art and science
we said hey this is art see the shape we
connected a bunch of dots over the years
we said see oh and this is science we
connected a bunch of dots we said it was
over here and then we hold onto those
shapes no I mean we subdivide them we
had a great discussion before the
lecture today about all the different
divisions within physics at all the
different divisions with India but we're
actually in a moment I think where the
shape of art and science is shifting
we're actually seeing a moment and part
of this art science connection that you
guys are doing here and that we're
seeing an exploding around the world the
number of artists and scientists who are
reaching for each other
speaks to me about the fact that the
momentum is driving us somewhere maybe
it's the nature of the inquiry
maybe it's the problems that we're
trying to solve maybe it's
the things we yearn for that's causing
us to want to reshape the way we see
ourselves I happen to love the shape and
momentum problem partly because I think
it's a dancer problem most dancers are
either shape dancers or momentum dancers
they're very few who do both with ease
you can learn to be the other but I
think about it too it's in terms of our
organizations and the way we structure
make something seen but dance in
particular brings about a shape so you
can see something and then you know it
dissolves that night and I think it
makes choreographers and choreographic
thinkers actually a very useful
commodity at this moment in time when we
were in so much motion and so much
change so I'm gonna spend a little time
at the beginning of this talk as I just
did with sort of these big general ideas
I want to talk a little bit about the
overlap between artists and scientists
that I've observed in my last decade of
doing that work also maybe comment on
some distinctions encouraged you to be
thinking about if you have questions or
comments but also maybe to pay attention
to the pictures that are forming in your
imagination we'll be able to stop and
talk every now and then sometimes I find
it's more interesting or it's curious
when people can bring forward the
pictures they see can't always formulate
it as a question and then I'm gonna tow
few little stories from my escapades
with the scientists so I think where I
want to take us let's talk for a minute
about how artists and scientists work
overlap what's the sort of congruence
between us I got to sit on a panel
recently with a man named Hadiya Mapuche
he's an applied physicist at Stanford he
also happens to be a ceramicist
and we were together on a panel and he
went first for 10 minutes and then I got
10 minutes and then we talked together
for 10 minutes sohe Dale got up and he
said ok artists and scientists are
searchers
but that's good that's really good I was
wasn't exactly dismissive I wanted more
and then like five minutes later I got
more because he came back to it and he
said searching is good for you
that I don't think I thought of before
and in my mind remember I said what are
the pictures for some reason the picture
that came into my mind when he said that
was a nutritional label like it's good
for you and it and that moment of that
picture helped me to understand about
searching as nourishment it's it's it's
nourishing to the body to the soul to to
those of us lucky enough to get to
pursue it and that's also what I mean by
if you can capture the image that's
happening in your mind because I think
our imaginations create those pictures
as a way to personalize data that the
way we bring our person to any data is
in there like for example if I said to
you my family always my father insisted
that we have Friday night dinners
together for the Sabbath and then we
could go play you know we could go out
but we had to have dinner together
I'm sure you're all creating a picture
in your mind right now I mean if I asked
you I suspect you'll be seeing families
at tables you would probably not see my
table you would see your table that's
what I mean you personalized the data
the stories so I really like and it's a
little bit like Heisenberg if you start
playing around with the images you might
not hear the words it's hard to do both
so I liked what had Dayo said that were
searchers I think another thing that
I've come to see about our fields and I
don't think this is only our fields I
think we could add probably religious
thought and I'm willing to add to that
major trio one more which would be
community organizing because I think
there's a very particular amazing
philosophy and way of being in the world
that organizers have that's very special
too but I would say we're obsessive
really obsessive and that has you know
good in a not so good side but it's an
amazing quality like when I met the
scientists initially with the biologists
you know I met people who had been
studying the same little organism for
like twenty thirty forty years or the
work that I know Sarah you're doing you
know it's incredible to me it's so
obsessive and kind of wonderful I think
we share a an interesting dilemma with
the public that is to say we are I
believe on in general misunderstood by a
lot of the public in different ways but
we share the dilemma when I first
started working with the scientists I I
had this thought that they had somehow
sold the public that they were always
that they had the truth and their fourth
date something changed it was horrible
and we had somehow sold the public on
the idea that we you know anything goes
we're so creative it's you know and that
the idea of rigor and discipline like
wasn't anywhere in sight but I'm lately
thinking that actually there's a there's
a study out that says that the public
likes art but doesn't like artists and I
thought maybe the scientists have the
reverse that maybe the public like
scientists but doesn't like science I
mean this is very general remember I
said I was starting with the big general
I hope you'll you you understand I know
this isn't entirely true across the
board but it is fun to think of these
sort of bigger ideas as we try to
contemplate this the world that emily
has laid out for us I think we share and
this is a this is related to obsession a
joy and tedium I know we mostly focus on
problem solving and things like that
the sort of creativity side where
artists and scientists are both creative
but I want to focus on some of these
other things although I think actually
tedium is a big part of creativity
there's something incredible about
repetition there's something incredible
about practice
and I think why it's so powerful in our
cases is because we only outcome I'm not
sure tedium is so nice if you are on an
assembly line
I mean I don't know I haven't been on
one but I so I don't I don't understand
this really totally but I I do know that
that this practice is like a huge part
of the life because it's part of setting
the conditions for the thing that's
going to happen and both scientists and
artists do this all the time we are
constantly setting conditions so that
something happens and then we change and
shift those conditions to make the thing
closer or further than what we imagined
or because we noticed something
happening we change the country change
the setups of those conditions I think
all that's pretty great we are also
especially in this last one I think we
begin to see the distinctions and ways
in which we are not the same when I'm in
rehearsal I think I'm making this thing
and something else happens in front of
me I may very well make a huge turn and
just say oh I'm not doing that anymore
I'm gonna go do this in fact I think
sometimes maybe artists we leave it too
soon maybe we don't stay around the
thing long enough I'm not positive about
that but I do wonder about that about
how long artists want to keep things
open and when scientists need to pursue
this particular theory and say this is
the thing I'm going for this is how it
played out for me at CERN and I told
Sarah she has to be sure to contradict
me with this little story because it's
kind of silly but I went to CERN before
they push the button I was there as they
were getting ready and getting close to
the things starting mm hm and I I met
just amazing people and they took me
around they showed me everything and I
was really we got into these big
discussions about the software that they
were that the the way they were setting
up the experiments because they were
looking for the Higgs boson
and they told me those kinds of things
that you get from scientists that I love
you know every time that we have one of
our smashing colliding particles
there'll be more data than exists at the
Library of Congress for example this one
it's one of the metaphors but they were
really looking for something and so I
kept saying to them you know like one
day a month could you not run your
programs and just smash them and see
what you see like what if something's
happening but that's it's like that
because I think in part in the end
artists may want to keep it wide open
multiple possibilities multiple answers
multiple ways of seeing not this one way
so that may be where we part company on
some big level or not we'll see what do
you see yeah serious good she's gonna
come out you got good mmm is this
interesting what these ideas about our
congruence and our discs on grants
perhaps I so here's another one when I
asked scientists about why they do what
they do you know it's really beautiful
and I I wish for them that there could
be many and there are you know many
movies and films and ways of sharing
this they don't say I do it for the
scientific method they usually say
something like I was you know young we
were outside I looked up at the sky I
saw this and I was transfixed or I just
met an earth scientist recently she's a
former ballerina and now she's an
amazing art scientist and she became an
earth scientist in part because her aunt
helped her understand how the plates of
the earth moved and she loved her aunt
so I mean it's very personal and yet for
so much in science I feel in potentially
the requirement of keeping the personal
out whereas in art we are encouraged
perhaps to our detriment to be personal
like that's part it's an understanding
that it's going to be a personal Drive
engine and expression I sometimes
thought for a while that maybe the more
personal you are in your profession the
less money you make I'm not sure that's
true but I didn't think about that for a
while
mothers nurses the answer is very
personal no money so I'm gonna pause and
see if you have any responses or any
questions or any images just from where
we got to so far with these sort of big
ideas
and sometimes I think you don't know so
why don't you just talk to somebody next
to you for a minute
about what you heard I'm serious
actually it'll be--it'll get it out of
your own head first I can just grab
somebody near you and don't be by
yourself you have to move just talk to
somebody about anything that's been said
so far you want to remember or you want
to dispute or you want to raise just
take a second okay
let's we'll come back thank you for that
so now does anybody want to say anything
out loud they either discovered observe
found out I have a question about one a
challenge about before we move on
they're actually looking for something
very specific no when they found that I
was very interested in my some work I
did with Darwin I find a little quote of
his that he liked to observe with and
without reason and I think both of those
are really at the core of it because we
want both we go at you know I could say
I'm thinking I'm pursuing an idea and
say a rehearsal I'll go after it really
hard for a while but yeah and of course
scientists are wide open to to change I
mean we know that's how viagra came
about and things like that they weren't
going after a pill to do what it does
they were thinking about something else
anybody else yeah so I was thinking
and other cultures or even Hasidic
business
okay then less body so what two words
that come out ecstasy the vibe that
we're going to definitely pursue one of
those in a minute yeah anybody else
anything it was a hand back there what a
question okay so before we jump into him
body man I'll just give you one quick
little example about this idea about
keeping things open when I started
working with the biologists on a piece
about genetics I had a little team of
biologists that I could call or email
when I had problems and I was
desperately looking for something to
work on in rehearsal and I came across
the term protein folding and I got
really excited because it was a verb
that's a great we go into her so we got
something to do so I sent out a little
note to them and said what do you guys
think about protein folding and I got
back right away to two responses one was
Liz that's too complicated stick to the
ethics and the other was how did you get
into protein folding so fast it's the
hottest subject in our field how did you
do that I thought both of its really
interesting but in time we actually did
quite a bit of work with protein folding
and when I eventually saw an animation
of what they thought protein folding was
I would not have called it protein
folding I mean what I saw I would give
it a different I might have said
something like and now this is a few
years ago so I'm sure it's more the
animations and the way it looks as much
of clear but I would have said something
like slowly wrapping around itself until
it gently drops to the bottom except
there is no bottom or something like
that
so I had a discussion with biologists
about whether if you say protein folding
does it affect your imagination remember
what I was saying about personalizing
data what's the picture and did they
think by calling it protein folding they
were affecting the way they asked their
questions would it affect the inquiry
and would it be interesting if for a
little bit they borrowed a creative
process of mine and ours which I would
say multiple words for the same thing
which gives so many different it comes
out of my community practice which is
that when you have problems you know
where people are fighting over something
if you have put multiple ways to say the
same
thing you open up a million doors for
people to come into contact with each
other and stay in the room and so I have
made that suggestion could you have like
ten ideas around protein folding that
you could hold open before you decided
to call it that just for the heck of it
would it change your research that's one
of those examples of where I believe at
the deepest level artists and scientists
working together we can really affect
the way we do our work so I like to
think of the spectrum is from embodiment
from from embodied learning to awe and
wonder and that all along this trail of
work we could intersect with each other
and things might occur that would be
useful so well we'll go now to this
question of embodiment which is an
interesting dilemma for a choreographer
especially a choreographer like myself
raised up in the world as I did probably
one of the worst jokes you could say to
me growing up would have been the joke
about interpretive dance which would be
pretend to be a tree and if you are a
serious artist you would laugh at that
pretend to be a tree I I came to
understand that the problem isn't being
the tree the problem is the pretense the
problem is the pretending that feels
terrible being a tree actually pretty
hard you know our ancestors it would
take them you know weeks of festivals
maybe drugs maybe all kinds of things in
order to become what they weren't I'm
gonna be the lion before we go on the
hunt I'm gonna be the Sun and make sure
it comes up tomorrow it's no small thing
to make yourself be what you are not
turns out that there are a lot of
choreographic processes that can help
people in or help me any way that I
developed in my own rehearsals because I
was interested in narrative not just
abstraction but a narrative which was to
figure out how to embody things in a way
that was purposeful not pretending it
didn't always lead to interesting
movement it always led to knowledge I
want to say that again
embodiment doesn't necessarily lead to
the most interesting movement and that
may be an issue if you are performing
for an audience it is absolutely a way
to comprehension and knowledge so I
think post modernists in a way we may
have thrown the baby out with the
bathwater and said wait wait we can't
pretend to be a tree and wait it's ugly
movement and no it doesn't go anywhere
let's not do it anymore
we gave up some of our most powerful
powerful instincts and tools that we can
use in so many ways so what do I mean by
this
like embodiment could be as simple as
here Emily can you just stand it for a
minute yeah if Emily and I guys say here
Emily let's shake you okay now we're
gonna separate so you guys we know that
cells split right look at that cell
split Wow we'll do it again okay cells
split by cow how do we signal oh I know
well signal one two three you don't
really know how they split and you find
out what's interesting about embodiment
is that even as simple as that is you
understand what you don't know really
fast and you ask really interesting
questions even faster because you want
to try to figure out what wait a minute
what is it who pulls is it a tear it
always it a separation is it what is it
and the body can begin to tell you that
not the most interesting dance although
I have to say the way Emily did it was
pretty interesting whether she did a
good job so so I was very interested in
in this question when I started working
in a scientists partly because I brought
all these questions with me with the
biologist but also the biologists want
and all the scientists want this they
want help from artists communicating
what they're doing this didn't just
start in this century you can go back to
the 14 15 16th centuries you see
scientists and artists trying to figure
out well how to represent
the stars how to represent you know
maybe suddenly God looks like a dragon
or God looks like an angel that the
issue of how we represent the unknown is
ancient we're just in our current form
of it so scientists really want two
things they asked me for two things when
we started working together with could
we communicate science in a way that the
public would care and could we help
people understand it better more easily
which I loved that's sort of Emily
alluded it to it in her introduction
we're going to bring contemporary dance
and biology together and make them both
comprehensible that's a really good plan
but it it did lead to some really
interesting choreographic issues for me
so I want to start I'm going to show you
a little clip now one of my early
discussions with the biologist was with
dick Linton at Harvard and he we were
having a long time all of a sudden he he
looked he looked off in the distance the
way people do I think when they want to
go in their imaginations and he said
I've got it I got it the dancers are all
lie down because DNA is inert and then I
started to notice that every time I was
in a conversation with any other
scientist they all had choreographic
ideas they were all pretty much
embodiment simple pretend to be a tree
ideas but they communicated really well
and I have this idea that if they could
say it it would be charming if I said it
it would be really bad art so we
developed this little it turned out this
wonderful sound designer I work with
Darren West took all their interviews
and he made a text and then the video
designer for the project made a video
and then eventually we also choreograph
to it we are going to show you this
little clip it's I have two just
appalling apology but you know in real
life the scale is doable when you look
at a screen you know it's complicated
you're not really getting the visceral
nature of it but I also want to say that
I was quite purposeful in keeping the
choreography simple because in this case
the two designers that I was working
with had made it quite complex so let's
do this one Heather thank you
so the so yeah I could imagine that
dancers would be you could start out by
just living dancers out and and floors
out dancers living dancers out in the
end
or do you know we head to one of the
it's the genome shuffles okay if you
want to put into advance because if you
look when we reconstructed the ancestor
you see all of the mammalian genomes if
you look when we reconstructed the
ancestor you see all of the mammalian
genomes or basically just reshuffle
pieces of the same
so so you could imagine that the dancers
would initially form themselves into
these secondary structures in the
shuffle in the genome right so that
means that say if I was a chromosome I
could break it my foot and have my foot
speed my knee but it would still be the
same chromosome but that's in his
version with somebody else you can see
some of what we've been discussing
repetition they're explaining of course
they're also I got into thinking about
science delivery systems in the context
of dance making the way when you read a
book of fiction and the kids only one of
the characters is a philosopher or
something you know how much you learn
when you're reading it was like well
right what kind of science information
could I get out how could I do it and
also what that what did I want people to
know so that later when we did in the
second act took a look at aging and at
perfection and at evolution people would
have some knowledge so they could come
along so there's a lot of information in
that clip that people were getting that
they could bring with them into into the
later stuff and I think it would be
interesting to do one more the little
biology clips and then I want to jump to
the physics because I know that's what
we're mostly gathered here for only be
this clip also gets at some of the
issues around embodiment one of the
first scientists I met was a woman named
Nancy Wexler who was responsible for our
understanding of Huntington's disease I
could go on and on about Nancy Wexler
and the amazing work of women scientists
and I call attention to her gender
because she did something incredible
there's not enough of a pedigree in the
United States to find out about the
Huntington's disease but there are
communities in Venezuela where almost
the whole town has it and she went there
with the whole team it wasn't just her
she really began this team work and she
brought pediatricians she bought water
experts she brought all kinds of people
with her as she began to work on trying
to understand the genetics behind
Huntington's she gave us her tapes and
when you look at the tapes you just
struck but as a choreographer you're
struck by the movement what is it that
happens up with Huntington's and you're
struck by this incredible like there's
Nancy holding these villagers just
holding them amidst this incredible
poverty and it's quite it's it's a whole
story in and of itself so we got
interested in whether we could embody
Huntington's which raised an ethical
question for us you know but the
genetics things we got big into ethics
because that's what's on everybody's
mind at the time which was what do we
have the right to do that
and we actually went frame by frame and
I'll show you that and then we advanced
it the later part of the dance it's not
so it's not as carefully crafted the
second part of the dance gets more at
that sort of holding I was talking about
and you'll see a character Gregor Mendel
is the sort of narrator the the sort of
spiritual guide to the piece and I
picked him because he's a scientist and
of course he's a religious figure and
it's I like that idea and reminding us
again that that connection had been made
and then dissolved back to our dots what
we connect and what we dissolve and what
what that lets us see so first the first
clip will just be the two dancers trying
to figure out what the hind ends looks
like and then the second clip is just a
little bit of the duet between Gregor
Mendel and Martha Whitman
just you more see
one of the things that we heard from the
scientists were that you never had in
the same room the researchers the
ethicists and the families who had
people with diseases that this work is
about and so when we toured that piece
we we in several occasions were able to
have panels where that was what occurred
and that brings me to this idea that one
of the things that art can do and it's a
question for the scientists as well is
that science is changing our lives so
much the way we think about ourselves
the way we see ourselves where do we get
to work that out where where do we get
to work it through I know sometimes I
used to say it's it's tiny it's like
when they decided Pluto wasn't a planet
for people of a certain age it was a
very sad thing but that's nothing that's
nothing compared to what's to our
understanding and how it's changing and
the possibility that one thing when
artists take on scientific content is
that it gives us that it turns the
concert hall into a town hall and an
opportunity for us to live together with
some of these with the implications of
these things so when we were touring
this piece I was approached by a
physicist at the University of Michigan
who said to me after seeing this we want
one and I said well no no I was done I
wasn't doing another one but it was
through him that I got to go to CERN and
and the reason I went is because I had a
meeting with the whole physics
department at Michigan and four so they
were all on time and that got me
wondering hmm dancers and physicists on
time really interesting because you know
that's important but at that meeting if
they were talking with great enthusiasm
and excitement about CERN and they and
one of the things that Gordy came said
to me is you know we're gonna really
understand how it all began we're gonna
be able to go back to the beginning
we're gonna know and I just said well
what about the other origin stories not
in defiance and not in opposition but
really out of curiosity what are we
gonna do about the other origin stories
not the stories themselves but the
what people believe him and you know I
just love the answer in that room was
it's really a big question isn't it
it wasn't like dismissive it wasn't like
no that's just religion it wasn't like
that it was like yeah
what about that so I thought oh maybe
maybe we should make that P and that
became the matter of origins that's that
was the beginning of that piece there's
a lot to say about it I don't know
rather than talk about it whether you'd
like to see some clips that might bring
you in a little bit into it there's we
have a clip of our research there would
you like to see that I went first time
on alone then I came back with one
dancer it's all I could afford one
dancer one film person and one
production person and we didn't even
know we were doing so we just film film
film and they it was really fun they we
got to go into the as I said they
weren't they hadn't pushed the button
yet so we got to be in the tunnels and
when everybody got so excited they all
came with their cell phones Ben was
dancing in the tunnel and you looked up
and there was just all these people with
their phones filming and you know I
think it's partly again that what
happened and sometimes I think these
cross-disciplinary transdisciplinary
things the whole point is to make you
excited about your own work it just gets
you to see your own work in a way you
never saw it before and and it makes you
happy to go back to work I sometimes
think that's all it that's all it needs
to be so this is a little bit longer I
hope it's okay it's um there's one part
you're gonna see this we're in the
cafeteria at CERN we're discussing an
equation and it's hard to hear what the
scientist is saying but he's going to
talk about butoh dancing as something to
think about and otherwise I think yeah
so this is a very improvisational
and we made this and sent it back to
them this is what we sent them after we
were there so they could understand us a
little bit
oh you know and one of the most amazing
thing that they were doing was they were
slamming themselves full force against
the walls of the room okay do that often
enough and at some point you end up on
the other side of the wall that's what
the bigger you are the heart of the wall
the harder it is for you to get through
that's this tunneling through the wall
is not easy to do
all of them do it they keep bouncing
against the wall again and again and
again they keep probing in a way the
wall until at some point by chance
randomly they they tunnel through the
wall
bless the actual sunrise
but this Sunday didn't have this all
computers
so they are living
and see if you have questions or things
on your mind or images or things you'd
like to discuss to think
mentioned earlier just a narrative and I
was wondering to what extent
you're hardcore even as about just about
narrative in general in my work I would
say that I'm I I on the spectrum of from
complete abstraction to you know let's
just be a natural theatre I hang out
more in the narrative end I always have
it's always interested in these stories
but the actual if you look and see it
it's very abstract the way in which we
get at it and in some ways I feel like
that's just more it's more truthful to
me the way the world is
it's neither entirely like we're having
this conversation you and I but
meanwhile there's that beautiful light
over there in the corner somebody's
putting on their clothes over here
there's people have been right you know
there's movement happening in the room
so this is happening but so is all this
other and that's what it feels like I'm
most like trying to find but I have to
say the science stories are riveting the
riveting and the backstories the stories
of who they are their biographies the
how they think how they it's riveting I
just taught a course at ASU an
experimental class I'm working on right
now called animating research and it's
sort of my an attempt I'm getting at as
to what might be ultimately some
relationships between artists and
researchers and what I decided to make
the course be is that the artist would
have to explicate something that the
researcher is doing where there's no
interpretation you have to use artistic
process to do it but you don't get to
interpret this is how they set up the
experiment this is the thing or this is
the something
secondly they had to make it then
meaningful to themselves as a person
which is where that personal purposeful
why am i drawn to this anyway and then
thirdly had to present it in a way that
the public would come and care so and my
reasons for doing this class is yes I'm
interested in the research getting well
there are two reasons one is I want
artists to be fearless about subject
matter I want them to be fearless that
we could take on anything
and that doesn't mean it has to be a
message piece and it doesn't have to be
about love or death or identity it could
be about all this other stuff that's
going on in the world and I wanted the
scientists and the researchers to begin
to see that the engagement practices
that artists have been in for the last
50 years are useful to science not just
science but the social science
researchers too because I met oh I was
working on another piece about poverty
with Charlie Siler from urban Bush woman
and we met with an amazing research team
from important University and I said
what would make you feel successful
there poverty Research Institute and
they said oh if we get on NPR and I'm
thinking no that cannot be the
definition of success it's like saying
the definition of success is to be at
bam downtown it's not there's so many
other ways we need to be in the world
right now and that can't be our
definition so that's a long answer to
your question but yes I like narratively
okay yes Emily
it's a mystery and Sarah and I in our
course we're dealing with physics
principles as money counters in an
introductory textbook and not so much
dealing with history behind them
although we think it's intriguing and
reader to delve a word starting to delve
into that but I'm curious because you're
working gauges it with both at your
curiosity and perhaps that you are
searching for fuel yeah for creation
well I think that my biography is
incredible and everything I thought when
I was researching just reading about
about their stories there's a section
for example about Marie Curie in the
physics piece and and you know her
Diaries unbelievable how she died she
slept every night with a little vial of
that stuff next to her bed it's like you
know you will never forget that and you
and when you understand what she did to
discover that stuff talk about tedium
obsession and weight I mean the stuff
was heavy oh my god so not not the thing
she found but the melting of all that
stuff so I think of it as an engine part
of it part of it as an engine to
connecting to the material and actually
we had a National Science Foundation
grant during the physics tour and we got
to research the audience before during
because we had a nooner mission and then
after because the second act was T and
you sat with scientists and artists and
other things happen and the I just want
to say that women no matter what their
age spiked in their interest in science
by going in the way we went in through
the stories and through the movement
through the dancing through the visuals
so much so that if you want to have more
women scientists we could talk about
intervention at certain places it
doesn't take away though from the
incredible substance of the research
itself the thing itself and we had a
just as much fun going in after that
stuff but maybe I would say that these
stories contextualize it for me in a way
are you using personal are you using
personal biography in the class at all
or is it part of the reading
they are guided by
yeah yeah I would agree with that yeah
but you know the same mystery I just did
a piece called healing auras about it
was the third of the science pieces that
was I worked with neuroscientists in
relationship to veterans coming back TBI
and and that work and there are two
although the science the actual smile
that's not sure we got into it quite a
bit in one section but they are - I was
really drawn to the story of the first
person to be in charge of our medical
corps in the military which is a man and
Jonathan Letterman and when you find out
what you know that's why they all died
on manassas they left them they didn't
think they were going to be anybody out
there dead but they they didn't have any
system and so when you read what he did
and how he thought it just it just will
drive you to stay on the subject I think
anybody else a quick question I know
it's probably yeah anybody else
something you'd like to talk about for a
minute or two or ask me about because if
not I have one in a 1 minute and 15
seconds of the matter of origins which I
would love to show you it's not exactly
the way you would see the piece its
Clips not only that the voice-over is
true to the piece but the voice-over
doesn't go over what you're seeing but
in this case for you it does okay
this lecture series is sponsored by a
Frankie program science and humanities
hosted by Whitney Community Center very
grateful and I want to also recognize
professor Robert children the series is
named professor Shalini is during that
sterling professor emeritus chemistry
molecular biophysics and biochemistry a
senior research assistant scientist in
diagnostic radiology and it's named in
his honor and recognition of his role as
a founding a fellow of the Whitney and
his ongoing shampoo symphony and media
of science and humanities in dialogue we
are so grateful to you for charting his
path in which we follow and for hanging
in there with us this semester for this
lecture series
in exchange I just wanted to lay that
important piece of this thing I too am
grateful I really love the opportunity
to get to think about these things
together and to find like-minded Souls
so we'll take the last one
what is the fundamental nature of
gravity what holds the universe together
why should I bother
is there a unified theory of everything
are there other dimensions where do we
come from where are we
and indeed welcome to CERN the European
Organization for Nuclear Research in
Geneva welcome to discern control son
our capstone shirts everything so cute
anything else all together thank you